with every clash comes change and the
opportunity for evolution injustice to
pits heroes against heroes and villains
against villains in an unprecedented war
a safer world and with the infinitely
rewarding gear system you're in charge
of how your journey unfolds matter of
your seasoned fighter or a new contender
the air is essential and injustice to
from far beyond the surface within this
system is an unparalleled depth that
gives you both the opportunity to evolve
your play style and look to achieve your
goals with every fight there's the
promise of reward each experience in the
arena brings more pieces of gear to
expand your customization options each
element of your loadout has its own
unique look and ability to boost your
base stats the maximum effectiveness
benefits increase as you level up with
each victory more specialized gear is
introduced this not only gives you
bigger boosts and more strategic
flexibility in combat but also opens up
almost infinite opportunities to
supercharge your look you'll either make
the right choice or I'll make it for you
some of the most powerful effects in
combat come from set bonuses grant into
loadouts of connected gear
the more pieces in a set you use more of
an edge you get Vantage's are earned
beyond physical gear augments abilities
and special moves are granted after key
achievements
[Music]
the gear system is real strength lies in
the freedom it gives you and players of
all levels and types it also gives you
the power to assemble your hero or
villain for the loadout and look that
fits your playstyle
keya evolution is controlled and adjusts
to working you're constantly
accumulating gear options gives you an
edge over your opponent both
stylistically and strategically now the
power and choice jewels